what's going on guys this is rob and
with thor 4 coming out and
us basically getting russell crowe zeus
one of the big questions people are
going to have here is could zeus have
defeated thanos and if he could have
defeated thanos
why didn't he where was he when all
that's going on okay i have an idea
about the second question but let's
answer the first question could zeus
have defeated thanos
yes absolutely uh at least thanos
without the infinity gauntlet absolutely
zeus would have beat the piss out of him
and it wouldn't have even been close so
here's the thing to understand about
thanos at least really kind of borrowing
from all the comics i mean in the marvel
cinematic universe everybody's weaker
just on average no one's really as
strong as their comic book version even
the display of power with the infinity
gauntlet wasn't as strong as as it was
in the comics honestly what was really
kind of shocking and doctor strange too
is that the kind of power wanda
possessed like when she took away black
bolt's mouth because black bolt sucks uh
that was one of the very few instances
that you've seen in the marvel cinematic
universe where it's kind of a carryover
from the comics i never actually
expected that for her to use reality
warping and to take away black bolt's
mouth so that he could kill himself
because he's an idiot so um here's the
thing when it comes to these characters
right let's say we just kind of borrow
from from marvel comics
thanos by and large the guy runs away
unless thanos definitively knows he has
the upper hand in a conflict he won't
fight he'll usually end up taking off
unless he has to fight unless something
has to happen like with drax a destroyer
it's usually that way he always avoided
a fight with drax the destroyer until
you got to annihilation when drax ripped
his heart out which is pretty cool but
that's usually how all that stuff works
when it comes to his character so one of
the things to know is that if a fight
were to occur between thanos and zeus
thanos would plan ahead of time he would
he would use prep time right the the
batman macguffin right the way in which
batman beats everybody is prep time but
he would basically plan ahead in order
to ensure that he would have some kind
of caveat so he would come out on top
but if they were just thrust into a
conflict with each other seemingly out
of nowhere right like zeus is just bored
and he knows thanos is out there in
space somewhere and thanos is minding
his own business and zeus just teleports
to him and just starts fighting him zeus
would beat the hell out of him right
just absolutely trash thanos it'd be
it'd be pretty rough having said that in
the marvel cinematic universe
i don't necessarily know we don't know
enough about zeus
but that does raise the question where
was zeus during all of that stuff that
was going on on earth right that why
wasn't zeus involved in any of that and
the answer to that question i think kind
of falls into the same way as it was
with the eternals why didn't the
eternals do anything because they were
told not to now i know this kind of
seems like just sweeping it under the
rug right just kind of a hand wavy
explanation but i think this is cool
because in the comics that's how it
played out and the comics the third
celestial host changed a lot of things
right i know the mcu plays by its own
rules right but let's let's borrow
because in the absence of just any other
explanation might as well go with that
one in the comics the way that played
out is of course you have the first
celestial host right the celestials show
up on earth they modify the genes of a
segment of humanity basically those
residing around like in and around
lumeria and atlantis and all that um and
so you got the eternals you got the
deviants and then the third group had
their genes modified so that at some
point mutants emerge that was the first
host the second host was when the
celestials came back to check on their
experiment and this and the deviants
attacked them right so the celestial
sink atlantis and all that kind of stuff
right initiated the great cataclysm and
all that the third host is when the
celestials came back and they found out
or kind of picked up on the idea that
like the asgardians and the olympians
and like the egyptian pantheon of gods
that they were all getting involved in
humanity right the humanity in different
parts of the world were worshiping the
olympian gods and the asgardian gods and
the egyptian gods and vishnu and all
those different guys and because of the
fact that it would basically take
humanity off the path of it evolving on
its own without any external involvement
from any godly beings or anything like
that the celestials were like stay hands
off keep your like keep your hands off
of my humans
right now get your stinking paws off my
humans you damn dirty gods like that's
basically what they were what they were
doing for those of you guys who know the
planet of the apes meme but um that was
the thing that's what was going on when
that happened the sky fathers launched
an attack against the celestials using
like the the what is it the um destroyer
armor that's what it is the name escape
before a second and like the celestials
just crushed the destroyer armor and
they were like if you keep us up we're
going to kill you all so either you stay
hands off humanity or we'll just
annihilate all of you and that led to
the sky fathers just being like okay
because like we want to live and we
don't want to die so like we'll just
we'll stay hands off
and that's basically how things went
from there it's not that far outside the
realm of explanation for that to be true
because one of the things to keep in
mind is that in the marvel cinematic
universe in the first thor movie we were
given an explanation that like way long
ago right a long long time ago in a
different part of the world that people
worshipped the asgardian gods and then
one day they just stopped and we never
really got an explanation why it's not
that far outside the realm of
possibility to believe that celestials
had shown up on earth and realized that
if the gods were basically interfering
with the evolution of humanity that
could threaten the existence of tiam
right like tiamat the dreaming celestial
that they could like end up destroying
the world or any number of things i mean
it happened with the watchers right the
watchers were like hey like we're super
powerful let's like you know hang out
there and let's help other races and
they gave one race the power of nuclear
energy and what did they do they
obliterated themselves so the watchers
were just like we're hands off now right
you know like they got broken up with
one time and never dated again
[Laughter]
but that's basically what went on there
so it's not that far outside the realm
of possibility to look at like what was
going on with the greek gods and to know
or at least to believe in some way that
somewhere along the line they were told
to stop interfering in the affairs of
humanity now whether that's the the
actual situation or not i don't entirely
know beyond that i don't really know
right i mean there are there are a
couple things to keep in mind so
everything with the celestials that you
saw in like the in that terrible last
eternals movie they borrowed a lot of
that from earth x and in the earth x
story is i understand that the various
gods came into existence because
humanity just literally believed them
into existence they willed them into
existence and the power of the gods
began to wane because humanity stopped
believing in them so i don't know if
they would go that far you know that
seems even a little far-fetched for the
mcu right it's a stretch
in a movie franchise with uh with a
giant purple guy who put some some gems
on his glove and blinked out half the
life in the universe right in the same
universe where you've got giant space
gods that made things can you really say
anything is a stretch in the marvel
cinematic universe
i mean you know twenty thousand foot
tall space gods whose heads are bigger
than the earth them going around
creating all things in existence that
fits that makes sense but you know
willing gods into existence that's a bit
of a stretch rob
that's a bit of a stretch
ian for the emcu nothing's a stretch
anymore in the mcu quite literally there
is a guy
waiting at the end of time
just hanging out at the end of time and
doing nothing but controlling a a
multiversal police force that polices
the time stream
nothing is a stretch
in the marvel cinematic universe that
word does not matter it's a platitude
but nonetheless right that's the burning
question that a lot of people are going
to have right like is there going to be
an explanation for why
the greek gods were not involved in like
the whole event with thanos it's one of
the issues you run into when you craft a
story like infinity war and avengers in
game and that's like your opening salvo
for like things are about to pop off and
then you start introducing groups later
on down the line it's like okay well
where were they when this was happening
right like why weren't they involved
when this was happening if this was
comic books we would just kind of chalk
it up and just say
whatever you know and just kind of walk
away from it i just sort of ignore it
but when you're talking about the
average movie going audience that can't
function if there's not some logical
connection between a and b then you
start running into like a breakdown
right where even the suspension of
disbelief begins to lose credibility
where people are like alright i mean
there's got to be some kind of
explanation here i mean who knows maybe
maybe the olympian gods became that tick
tock video right you guys know the one
that i'm talking about you know are you
an adult yeah are people doing things
that you don't like yeah introducing
minding your own business right like
maybe that's what it is right where the
olympian gods are like does this affect
us no well then it's none of our damn
business so we're just gonna sit over
here and we're gonna keep our mouths
shut and we're just gonna let that thing
do its thing i don't know one of the
theories that i have seen going on right
now is that the the events of infinity
war in avengers in game didn't matter to
zeus and those guys because they were
dealing with before the god butcher that
gore was literally traveling traveling
around the universe and just killing
different gods and that was their focus
that's what they were basically looking
at and there's room for that right i
mean that kind of thing happens in
marvel comics all the time a really good
example of that is while civil war was
happening on earth in marvel comics
annihilation was taking place literally
richard ryder nova shows up on earth and
is like okay so like avengers i need
your help basically annihilus has
escaped or has invaded from the negative
zone and is just like the annihilation
wave is just spreading across the
universe quite literally me and
star-lord are leading a group of
refugees who are just fleeing for our
life they captured galactus right the
silver surfer is powerless everything is
dying and then it turns out that humans
are just fighting each other in civil
war and he's like why are you even this
doesn't even matter man like some guy
killed like a few hundred people in
stanford connecticut you know golly gee
a single tier rolls down my cheek we got
more important things to worry about
let's go deal with the potential
destruction of the universe right that's
way more important that kind of thing
happens all the time so i feel like that
would be a great explanation when it's
like why weren't you guys involved in
like thanos and all that kind of stuff
and and literally zeus is like what do
you think is more important to us right
half of humanity and just mortal life
being blinked out of existence because
we're immortal we can't die so it's not
like we could be dusted right like we
would be fine and uh like do you think
it's that right thanos some demigod with
like a shiny glove blinging out half the
life or like a being who can
legitimately travel around and is
legitimately killing various people
right like various godly beings that are
out there that's more important to us
that would make more sense right to me
that would that would make more sense is
it kind of hand wavy sure but it fits in
perfectly with the plot right and at
this point why not just roll with it so
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments right like what's your
all's theory for why it is that zeus and
them did not intervene during the whole
series of events with thanos and the
infinity gauntlet and there's another
question let me know if you guys are
getting tired of people asking that
question right well where were they
during infinity war uh well here's a
question why does it matter who cares
just enjoy the movie right like let me
know what you guys think
thank you all for watching i will catch
you all later
peace